alors maintenant il y a une grande compétition nous
avons rocky nous avons Schwarzenegger nous l'
appelons schwarzi et nous avons dolphy nous
allons gagner
dolphin green qui t'appelle toujours fourmis
euh
ma mère mon père ouais et tu m'appelles juste
Hans ouais et euh c'est à peu près tout ouais
ouais mais pourquoi as-tu changé ton nom
de fourmis en Dolph
c'était trop allemand peut-être tu sais et
ouais petit allemand et autre Dolph était
tu sais c'est mon inhabituel ouais tu sais c'est le
Show Business tu sais ouais c'est le
Show Business oui il n'y a pas d'affaires
comme  Showbiz t'as compris oui t'es
suédois oui mais à Stockholm il y a
30 ans oui approximativement ouais
tu fais quelle taille euh
195. et tu pèses quoi euh
en ce moment
environ 105 kilos
tu portes deux fois champion d'Europe de
karaté mais t'es intelligent  aussi tu es
fort mais tu es intelligent toi tu
étudies le chemix depuis six ans la
technique du shimmy ouais ouais la
technique du shimmy la technique du shimmy et puis tu
portes un modèle pour lequel ils sont
sans succès pendant environ six mois et
puis tu as rencontré Grace Jones
où  dans euh backstage euh son concert à
Sydney je travaillais là-bas pour la
sécurité ouais et euh
je viens de la rencontrer elle était euh ils avaient
de la nourriture là-dedans et j'avais faim alors je
suis allé ensemble ils sont vraiment tombés
amoureux de ça tu veux dire  oui j'ai fait combien de
temps ça a duré quatre ans est-ce que tu l'as
suivie dans un excès
dans un excès je veux dire pas de sommeil et d'autres
choses
non non je ne l'ai pas non non
non non c'est la raison pour laquelle nous avons
rompu en fait ouais
la séparation a été difficile  ouais il a
fallu quelques années pour s'en remettre
ouais c'était difficile et maintenant ça va
maintenant je vais bien je suis célibataire était-ce un
problème pour toi avant que tu sois célèbre
pour t'appeler Mr Grace Jones euh
ouais mais personne n'a jamais  appelle-moi comme ça mais
c'est oui évidemment je ne le ferai pas je ne le ferai pas
sérieusement mais euh ouais c'était un problème je
pense que c'est toujours
c'est toujours difficile je veux dire si tu sors
avec quelqu'un qui est célèbre tout le monde
va lui parler et maintenant je suis  dans l'
autre situation tu sais en face et c'était
dur mais moi je m'en suis plutôt bien sorti je
pense que
la table est tournée tu sais ouais ça t'a
aidé ouais
ça m'a rendu fort je pense m'a rendu fort
quand quand tu étais en vue de tuer
ça t'aide d'être avec le super Jones maintenant
ouais ce film était juste un
walk-on qui était une partie où euh
tu sais qu'ils avaient juste besoin d'un gars pour tenir
une arme ouais ouais
j'ai dit bien ouais c'était avant que j'étais
vraiment  ouais tu sais ouais avant que
j'étudie vraiment le théâtre ouais les
filles devraient être ravies de tu sais
les filles ouais
j'espère donc tu sais
ouais je fais de mon mieux ouais
et les hommes
ça arrive ouais tu aimes le sexe euh
ouais
n'est-ce pas difficile  maintenant avec l'âge d'
être si beau
merci
euh je pense que ça l'est je pense que tout le monde l'est
quand tu es un beau mec comme toi et
tu as tellement de succès avec les filles et
il y a ce problème tu sais ouais je
sais je
ne sais pas  sais que j'ai été je prends mes
chances mec
pourquoi as-tu été choisi parmi
8 000 personnes
pour jouer dans Rocky 4 pour être
même Dragon pourquoi quand tu as 8 000
personnes pourquoi ils t'ont choisi
euh ce que quelqu'un devait  obtenez-le vous savez
ouais et ouais bien sûr eh bien c'est difficile
si vous voulez trouver un gars qui ressemble à
un mordeur ouais et vous pouvez bien bouger
et qui veut se connecter et
qui regarde la partie visuellement vous savez
alors vous ne le faites pas c'est un  combinaison difficile
et je pense que ce n'était pas un
problème pour vous de devenir célèbre en tant que
mauvais
euh
c'était un problème pendant un court moment je veux
dire pas mal
parfois
je suis célèbre comme un mauvais de toute façon oui je sais j'ai
entendu
pouvez-vous  dis-moi comment as-tu envoyé
l'étalon à l'hôpital pendant le tournage
de Rocky IV
il a affirmé qu'il était il était blessé je
veux dire que nous étions tous les deux nous avons tous les deux été touchés un
peu ouais je ne sais pas
je suppose qu'il est allé à l'hôpital ouais combien
de temps
il était en fait pendant deux semaines qu'est-
ce que tu lui as fait pour
l'envoyer à l'hôpital je pense qu'il était juste
fatigué ouais tu es un bon gars
cet étalon te demande de devenir
plus fort pour Rocky 4 et pour le
Punisher le producteur Kamen  t'a demandé d'
être plus mince pourquoi
euh
parce que le Punisher le personnage que je
joue là c'est un gars qui est euh c'est
un personnage antisocial qui
vit dans la rue il n'a pas la
chance de s'entraîner il ne mange pas
correctement il est psychotique  et il ne
va pas au gymnase tous les jours donc il serait
mince pour avoir un look dessiné tu sais et
j'aime être plus mince de toute façon je pense que ça a l'air
mieux est-il vrai que tu n'as
accepté que de jouer The Punisher  après qu'ils
t'aient dit de devenir plus mince et de te
teindre les cheveux je savais que je devais me teindre les
cheveux parce que c'est basé sur une bande dessinée
tu sais une bande dessinée très célèbre
Batman aux états ouais ce mec a fait
tuer sa femme et sa fille non ouais
c'est lui c'est un flic qui fait tuer sa famille
par des trafiquants de drogue et il devient un
peu fou tu sais et il commence
à se venger de ces gars et euh il est
fou il est en train de se venger il
parle à Dieu il parle à Dieu il est euh
c'est très brutal  ce n'est pas un bon gars qui
prend le méchant et le met et l'emmène
en prison généralement il les tue ouais ouais
c'est juste une punition alors maintenant il y a
une grande compétition nous avons rocky nous avons
Schwarzenegger nous l'appelons schwati et
nous avons dolphy nous le ferons  gagner l'essentiel de
ma carrière est devant vous savez dans les années 90
ouais les 10 prochaines années je pense que dans je
pense que les deux autres acteurs que
vous mentionnez ils ont commencé beaucoup
plus tôt donc je pense que c'est une question de
continuer quelque chose plutôt que de
rivaliser si  tu avais le choix d'être Kirk
Douglas Charlton estan John Wayne Albert
Lancaster qui choisiras-tu d'être
euh je pense à Lancaster depuis
combien de temps es-tu à Paris maintenant euh euh
je suis ici depuis environ cinq heures
tu cherches un  fille
suis-je toujours je connais un endroit
c'est le meilleur endroit ouais